this former industrial site is about to
become home to the UK's first new Coal
Mine in 30 years
the proposed Woodhouse colliery aims to
produce coal for the steel industry from
a seam extending from this protected
Cumbria Coastline far out under the
Irish sea the local Council couldn't be
happier we've waited a long time for it
the community have waited a long time to
eat so we believe it's the right
decision it's the right thing for us
here the hard work that's gone in from
our community and supporting this our
local Council that's all now been
recognized and I'm delighted that the
government have Now supported this
decision West Cumbria mining the
australian-backed company behind it
promises 500 local jobs but what of the
global impact of the three million tons
of coal each year they will produce the
government's perfectly logical view is
that because our steel makers currently
import coking coal and will continue to
do so the impact of a local mine on
climate would be neutral or even
beneficial you follow the logic of this
decision through it either means that
this coal mine will only operate for a
limited amount of time because our steel
industry has to reach Net Zero by about
2035 according to the government's
advisors or that the government's
prepared to pass on its carbon-cutting
obligations to Future governments and
future Generations
local campaigners are in disbelief
they've heard all the evidence they've
seen the results for themselves they've
been and seen the communities that have
been flooded out as a result already of
global warming
and they're going ahead with coal mine
it's just
yeah really really upset and really
disappointed
what does it also say about our
International rhetoric on climate it's a
terrible decision it's a terrible
decision for our energy policy for our
climate policy and it won't provide the
jobs that people in Cumbria need they've
come up with a solution which is going
to make us make a mockery of us
internationally which senior
conservatives have said is the wrong
decision it's a government that is out
of ideas and that is stuck in the past
the last mine in this town closed in
1986 and now a new coal era begins but
in a world that's more than half a
degree warmer than it was then and
getting warmer all the time Tom Clark
Sky News Whitehaven